collecting trading cards i've been
considered a nerd
most of my life i was sacrificing going
out with my friends
going out on dates and things like that
and in august we sold eight cards with
3.9 million
which became the most valuable trading
card ever sold
[Music]
i am ken golden and i am the founder and
chairman of golden auctions
golden auctions is the world's largest
marketplace for sports collectibles
trading cards
and memorabilia i have been
in this business buying and selling for
about 43 years now since i was 12 years
old
hey everybody i promise you an unboxing
today of some really cool stuff that
we've got in for golden elite i'd love
to show you the t206 wagner
this is known as the holy grail it is
the most famous trading card of all time
the 1952 tops mickey mantle is
considered
one of the iconic cards in the hobby
this card is
jackie robinson's rookie card of course
jackie robinson famous for breaking the
color barrier in 1947.
luka doncic is extremely popular they
feel he is the
future face of the mba this one is
limited to
10. between these uh four cards we have
from a low of six and a half million to
a high of nine million
depending how frenetic bidding gets
which is uh
quite remarkable when you look at four
little pieces of cardboard
golden has really taken off over the
past several years
especially over the past year i think
with the coveted lockdown
a lot of people got nostalgic they
started looking through old collections
they're looking for things to do
and during that time my company kept
sending records with high prices
and of course anytime you get a record
high it brings a lot of new collectors
into the marketplace
trading cards are issued in boxes of uh
packs generally and you do not know what
you're going to get
and oftentimes the box may be very
expensive
so what has happened is that there are
now
things called breaks you participate in
a live break
2021 tops baseball series one
we're looking for autograph cards we are
looking for rookie cards
let's see what we got there may be 12
different
individuals who buy into that and
somebody will break which means open up
the box
in front of a large audience of people
on the internet
and you get the experience of seeing
what you won out of the packs
oh there's a throwback mike piazza
it makes it affordable so that many
people can participate it makes it
social because everybody's rooting for
everybody to get the good cards
it's also a bit like sports betting but
whether that's something
is a hundred dollars or a hundred
thousand you don't know until it's open
my favorite item and my most valuable
item
is a bat that was used by babe ruth
i wouldn't want to put a value on it
except to say it's over a million
dollars
i'd always been someone who dealt in
vintage cards but a new phenomenon that
i noticed that there was this
revolution happening because the younger
generation they wanted to collect
cards of people they grew up with and
they wanted to collect cards
of people that were popular now ronaldo
rookie card
soccer is exploding he is the number one
rookie card to have in soccer right now
we famously sold a lebron james card
for 1.8 million dollars very recently
we sold a kobe bryant card for
approximately 1.79 million dollars
pristine baby kobe bryant pristine
chrome refractor should be looking at
about half a million on this
i've always considered myself a small
business and a small business owner
being able to interact they'll send me a
picture hey you know i've got this ball
what is this worth
i've got this card what do you think
this kobe's worth i answer every single
solitary message and when i wake up in
the morning
there's uh you know dozens more and no
matter how large golden gets
you know i at least i'm always going to
look at it as my small business
trading cards really when you think
about it they're part of society
and they are true pieces of art you know
it
brings back a different era it really
been a dream i mean
it's just incredible to be able to spend
your life
and wake up every day being able to
handle and collect the same things that
you did
when you were 12 and 13 year old now all
of a sudden in the business
we have people like mark wahlberg
opening up packs of cards on tv with his
kids
we have individuals like kevin durant
and dwyane wade
mike trout lebron james talking about
his trading cards we are now
part of pop culture and that is why i
think you've seen the popularity grow
and that is why i think the future is
incredibly bright for many years to come
thanks for watching for more videos like
this you can stream bloomberg quick take
for free 24 7 in
any of the places below get live news
coverage interviews deep dives shows and
documentaries on the stories that you
care about most
and be sure to follow or subscribe to us
on twitter youtube instagram and
facebook